de ses yeux ou l'est de vraies larmes
qui faisait comme une rivière de
diamants jusqu'à ses pieds
c'est l'histoire d'une princesse victime
d'un sortilège un jeune prince va tenter
d'aller la délivrer à travers cette
quête j'ai traversé des épreuves qui va
se découvrir lui-même il va découvrir sa
propre nature et va rencontrer des
personnages fabuleux des personnages
comme ce monstre à trois têtes sous
cette cape noire une danseuse sur des
échasses qui apporte aucune touche
aérienne et onirique
pour moi c'est un conte
dansé chorégraphié parce que c'est une
rencontre entre la danse et le conte ce
spectacle la citadelle de cristal et
jouer ici à luisant mais il sera aussi
donnée dans trois communes rurales du
département dans le cadre du festival
légendaire il ya une vraie mission
justement d'accès à la culture pour tous
et effectivement pouvoir aller sur dans
des zones où il est plus difficile donc
ces publics empêchés pour avoir accès à
la culture l'autre mission de la
compagnie qui a créé le festival en 2000
était de redonner ses lettres de
noblesse aux comptes on a toujours eu à
coeur de faire vivre revivre le compte
de partager ses histoires qu'on aimait
de recréer justement cette discipline
artistique qui avait quasiment disparu
en france on est partis avec deux trois
communes et puis finalement on a réussi
à faire un maillage territorial jusqu'à
une quinzaine de communes
sur la quarantaine de représentations
une partie est compté dans les ehpad les
foyers d'accueil et dans une prison pour
apporter à tous un peu de poésie et de
merveilleux
[Musique]